bienvenue à paroles autochtone ici c'est
mélissa mollen dupuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une question du lis qui me demande
y at il des communautés autochtones au
québec où les gens vivent en
autosuffisance
j'aimerais tourner la question et doit
plutôt qu'en les premières nations hôtes
elle perdu leur capacité à s'auto
suffire faut pas oublier que la raison
pour laquelle on est dans des réserves
dans les communautés c'est
malheureusement parce que il ya eu des
politiques gouvernementales et la loi
sur les indiens et une pratique née en
place pour détruire notre capacité à
nous auto suffire les mots qu ont eu des
politiques mis en place pour les
empêcher de vendre les produits de leur
agriculture
les innu par exemple on nous a empêchés
d'aller pêcher dans la rivière à côté de
laquelle on habitait c'était des
pratiques qui ont été mis en place pour
nous rendre dépendants justement de
l'économie qu'on dit canadienne et
aujourd'hui on en voit les effets mais
ça veut pas dire qu'on va accepter ça
sans rien faire et encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup de communautés travaillent très
fort à devenir autosuffisants
au niveau économique au niveau
territorial et je pense que on peut pas
voir encore le même effet qu'on avait il
ya cent ans
mais on voit qu'il ya un désir de
pouvoir s'affranchir de cette politique
qui nous a justement comment seront
tenues des bâtons dans les roues il ya
plus de 2 il ya plus de 100 ans
alors merci beaucoup pour ta question
j'espère pouvoir y avoir bien répondu
j'espère que vous n'allez pas hésité à
nous envoyer d'autres et à partager
cette vidéo soit une belle semaine